wildfire which is another um  of the quasi-magical things is uh you  know  plays a especially big part in the  battle of the black water  was partly inspired by the legends of  greek fire that the byzantines used  you know which supposedly we've never  been able to duplicate the byzantines  kept it a secret they  they used this greek fire on attacking  fleets from other nations and somehow  the secret was lost and now we don't  know what was in greek fire but um you  have resurrected  this yeah it's a little bit greek fire  it's a little bit nape bomb it's a  little bit nitroglycerin  it has the coolest characteristics and  it's it's  jade green it burns with green flames  why because i thought that would be cool  and indeed when we saw it on film it was  really cool  um yeah there are chemicals that will  emit only green light so it's  perfect you can just say that's in the  in the mixture and you're  you're good for my tweets right